[Musique]
c'est un mascara jardin botanique de la
réunion que s'est déroulée la journée
académique de l'éducation au
développement durable ce lundi 5 juin et
c'est vraiment l'occasion de valoriser
toutes les actions qui sont portées par
nos élèves de l'académie que ce soit des
écoliers des collégiens des lycéens sur
la thématique du développement durable
avec la participation de nos différents
partenaires sur la thématique d'aider
voilà aujourd'hui on travaille beaucoup
sur la thématique des déchets la
thématique
du potager je sais que les élèves ont
émis le souhait de travailler beaucoup
sur la ressource en eau sur la mobilité
sur différents sujets encore qui restent
à développer à la Réunion 400 élèves
impliqués dans cette démarche sont venus
présenter leur projet ce qu'on fait
c'est que
on
gaspillent on fait un tri et tous les
déchets végétaux et tout et ben on va
tout donner aux poules et aux lapins
donc bah il y a moins de gaspillage on
fait des serviettes hygiéniques
et en fait pour faire une version plus
recyclable on peut remplacer ce tissu là
le tissu éponge
par une serviette on continue mais on
vous découper les papillons ensuite il y
a le
tissu imperméable pour les plantes et
vous pouvez remplacer par du paradis
c'est après pour éviter de polluer la
planète en fait parce que on veut
utiliser plusieurs fois la même chose le
département qui porte un plan de
transition écologique et solidaire à
présenter son dispositif Bic budget
d'initiative citoyens on dit aux jeunes
que s'ils sont porteur d'un projet et
s'ils ont besoin de financement et bien
ils peuvent demander à leurs professeur
référents de venir sur ce stand d'être
au courant que ce dispositif est ouvert
à tous les établissements que ce soit
école primaire école maternelle collège
et lycée tant que le projet rentre dans
le cas de la transition écologique qui
peuvent être éligibles à ce dispositif
une convention cadre également été
signée ce jour entre la collectivité et
le rectorat le département est un
partenaire quotidien c'est la
collectivité territoriale de référence
pour les collèges cette convention nous
l'avons voulu parce que nous avons déjà
évidemment une convention cadre pour un
centre de sujets avec le département et
nous l'avons voulu spécifiquement sur le
développement durable et l'éducation
développement durable parce que nous
travaillons déjà beaucoup beaucoup avec
le département le département a un
beaucoup d'actions pour le développement
durable et nous avons voulu structurer
par exemple le plan un million d'arbres
nous travaillons beaucoup avec le
département dans les établissements
scolaires le plan anti-gaspi ils ont un
dispositif aujourd'hui sur l'éducation
citoyenne où il finance des projets dans
les collèges donc beaucoup beaucoup de
d'actions que le département mène
beaucoup d'actions que nous menons dans
l'académie et nous voulions structurer
rendre un peu plus visible encore ses
actions communes et en synergie avec le
département et l'éducation nationale la
journée s'est déroulée sur le magnifique
site départemental de mascara qui tout
au long de l'année d'acteurs de
l'éducation au développement durable
alors nous nous avons la chance
d'accueillir ici à Mascara dans
justement cet objectif de développement
durable de nombreuses classes de
nombreuses scolaires des petits jusqu'au
plus grand et de leur proposer sur ce
site magnifique de nombreuses animations
qui sont en lien justement avec cette
grande thématique également au programme
de la journée la remise de diplôme
académique aux établissements
nouvellement labellisés en démarche de
développement durable
[Musique]